okay today I'm going to talk to you
about life cycle assessments so there's
millions and millions of products out
there and every single product has some
kind of impact on the environment
what a lifecycle assessment does is it
looks at the different stages from the
second we start extracting the raw
materials to the moment that that object
or that product is disposed of to see
its impact on the environment and
there's four stages we need to know
about life cycle assessments the first
step we need to know about is choice of
material so let's just as we as we go
through I'm going to relate this to a
particular products just a random one
that founder of this stapler right here
and I'm going to relate the different
stages to that particular product so
first of all choice of material we need
to get that raw material in the first
place and what impact can that have on
the environment so if for example we
have a metal we have to extract the
metal or from underneath the Earth's
surface so that requires mining now this
mining might have lots of vehicles
coming in lots of lots of work going on
here
so habitats might be destroyed here to
make this mine in the first place also
quite a lot of pollution might be
produced by all of the vehicles required
for mining also so the metal there's
metal in this paper right here secondly
anything that requires chemicals or
plastics we're going to need to extract
crude oil from from the from beneath the
oceans or from beneath the ground in
order to do that again from so
extracting this crude oil is going to
require a lot of energy and could
release a lot pollution again this
stapler contains plastics both of these
things are true this stapler so this
stapler making this tape has already had
some kind of impact on the environment
so the next step to think about is
manufacture
so that's actually making this product
in the first place getting the raw
materials and turning it into this
product that we see before us now so for
example by making this stapler first of
all I'd have to extract the metal from
the ore and that might needs the process
of electrolysis if it's aluminium for
example would need the process of
electrolysis so it requires a lot of
energy it requires lots of energy and
we're using fossil fuels to to to
generate our electricity we're also
going to be producing a lot of pollution
during this process now pollution in
manufacturing companies we could be
producing lots of air pollution also
loads and loads of manufacturing
processes loads and loads of
manufacturing protists use water so
where does that water go afterwards does
it go straight back into rivers and if
so that's not great for the environment
at all so again there's lots of energy
that goes into making a product like
this okay the third step is product use
so how much so what's the impact on the
environment this product has during its
lifetime now this product here will have
a very very little impact on the
environment during its lifetime because
it's you know it's not damaging the
environment as I staple sheets together
at all however other products can so for
examples paint during its lifetime in
its uses it can release toxic fumes so
pink release toxic fumes if we have if
we've made fuels different fuels during
their lifetime they could produce
greenhouse gases so again it depends
upon what the product is on what it's
going to produce cars for example will
produce pollution as well and also if we
have fertilizers so if you have
fertilizers put onto crops to help them
grow those fertilizers could go
into lakes and cause or basically
damaged ecosystems so it completely
depends upon what product it is
depending upon the damage it has during
its lifetime so when we no longer use
the product let's say my stapler is now
broken I need to dispose of it I need to
get rid of it so let's think about
different problems with disposal now if
I just chuck this stapler in the bin got
rid of it it's broken bin it then it's
going to go to a landfill site so that
rubbish should be collected up it taken
in a lorry to a big landfill site and
that will just be dumped there now this
takes up lots of land and it can also
pollute this local area so that there is
an example of landfill what else can
happen to a lot of products is they get
burnt so we can incinerate them now this
obviously produces pollutants so it can
produce greenhouse gases well I should
say gas is underneath it could reduce
greenhouse gases but they could also
produce other toxic chemicals as well
now however disposal can actually be
less of a negative so for example the
plastic within here and the metal near
could both be recycled so by recycling
by recycling we're actually having less
damage on the environment so any product
that you're able to recycle it's really
positive when we look at this element of
the lifecycle assessment so that is the
lifecycle assessment of all products to
see the impact that opponent has during
its use thank you